you go to brazil that you have one
culture you go to colombia it's a
completely different culture you go to
argentina it's completely
cultural and and regulations
[Music]
sergio fogle thank you so much for being
on my show good afternoon
good afternoon good morning for me good
morning yeah so how are you i mean
you're in uruguay now
and how is everything with kovid oh this
is like an island it's
uh we have a very very few cases
um there's not a single person right now
in hospital wow okay
okay you know so what i love about this
is that this is actually going to be
showed
in a few weeks so this is always a fun
test to see how
things are now and then in a few weeks
when this gets published to our page
we're going to see what actually happens
but let's be optimistic and see that
everything is good that
that when this show is aired we have
zero cases incredible funnily enough or
actually not
funny pretty sad i had a show with an
entrepreneur from israel about a month
and a half ago
when there were zero cases and and he
said yeah everything is fantastic it's
great
and then i said well let's wait and see
what happens and the show is gonna air
this week
and the first sentence is that and i say
to on the show
well let's be optimistic but obviously
we know what's happening in israel now
so we're going to give it another try
sergio i want to i want to spend as much
time as we can talking about emerging
markets
you're an expert in you know in
digital in fintech and your deal and
you're one of the most you know renowned
innovators and entrepreneurs of uruguay
and latin america
a limited partner at j ventures where we
work together
so much is going on you are dealing with
one of the most incredible
industries one of the most fascinating
industries because you're actually
dealing with you know revolutionizing
people's lives in the way they
interact with you know businesses and
consumers
i traveled to mexico last year with with
one of my best friends from stanford
i noticed how the credit card revolution
and digital banking revolution is just
starting out
it was incredible please tell me a
little bit more about you
and what is the local
okay so where do i start let me first
tell you a bit about
myself i was born here in uruguay i
[Music]
did aliyah i went to live in israel
when i was 20 years old
studied at the technion worked uh
for ibm then i went to do
my mba at um at insead in france
very international school yeah and then
for family reasons we wanted our kids to
grow near their
grandparents so with my wife we decided
it was very very tough decision we
decided to move back
to uruguay but we
felt all the time very very attached to
israel where we lived for
almost 10 years wow and because of the
offensive
we were always very very international
we just
love to travel and visit the world with
different people and cultures and so on
yeah um so after a stint
working for a for large companies
we set up our first uh our first venture
together
my wife and me and myself so i'm going
to give you one
big piece of advice never do a a
a company with your wife or loved one
because you
put too much at risk that was a very
very bad idea i've heard that
quite a few times yeah yeah don't mix
the two things also with with best
friends don't start a company with your
best friend
yeah that's that's a good idea so first
company was a failure then
my second one is was a telecoms company
a voice over ip company
which we started back in the year 2000
and it's a
it's still running very very small
because
who uses voiceover ip we did a
long distance international phone calls
so i guess no one does an international
phone calls anymore
and and then
12 years ago we started the
astropay which then we spend
from that company who span off g local
but before you so before you tell me
what these are
i want you to tell me a little bit about
the market latin america
you know hundreds of millions of people
you know coming from israel and from
from from north america there it's a
different
it's a different market it's a different
lifestyle different mentality
what is happening in terms of fintech
and the way consumers are interacting
with
with come with small businesses up until
astro pay and d local come into the
market
okay so first of all you need to take
into account that
there is not a a country called latin
america
it's very very different you go to
brazil that you have one culture you go
to colombia it's a completely different
culture you go to argentina it's
completely
cultural and and regulations right and
when you talk about fintech
uh regulators play a very very big part
of course so you go to brazil and you'll
find that
almost everybody has a credit card or a
debit card
but you go to some other countries and
you see that
credit cloud penetration is quite low
right
now something that is quite common to
all these markets and
not only these markets we also work in
countries like
like india or indonesia or
or africa something that happened is
that you see many many countries
where a credit card penetration is very
low
and they are completely frogging the the
credit card
and going straight to wallets straight
to digital digital wallets
yes yeah so that the biggest
case uh greatest example is actually
china you go to china i was there
late last year and then
nobody is carrying a wallet anymore
so people it's the mobile phone you go
you go to a restaurant you pay scanning
your a qr code
you go to to a store again it's
wechat pay everywhere yeah maybe alipay
but it's it's all incredible
yeah now the the
the pain that we come to solve is that
all these people with this actually all
of those countries they have some
preferred payment payment method because
everybody everybody is paying
and in many cases people are going out
of uh
are walking away from cash yeah in some
places people
pay scanning a qr code in some places
they give a
a debit card a credit card in many many
cases it's a it's a
credit card but it's not visa or
mastercard branded
so you go to argentina you have many
people with a
card called target
you go to mexico and people pay with
them with cash they like to go to
also and pay cash and you go to
india you have all these wallets
so it's all good for the consumers
because the the the
local businesses accept those payment
methods
but when an international merchant goes
we
called merchants to actually do it
anyone who set
payments right a company that wants to
sell into these markets and we are
talking about very very
very big markets you go and you sell
into
those markets and you find that people
either
do not want to pay with a credit card if
they have it or they cannot pay
so let's give you know the classic
example you have a ride sharing service
who wants to to penetrate into a market
let's say into a country in latin
america that
you know there is a very low penetration
of credit cards or
or something of that sort and all of a
sudden they're stuck
because they don't have they are used to
getting payments
through you know your credit card and if
you if the country doesn't have credit
card then it doesn't matter that you
have the drivers and the cars because
you can't accept the payments
and then here you are coming in and
you're saying okay let's think of a
creative way to to bridge this gap
between the local
and the international exactly
right in the middle so that was a great
example when uber came it was the first
ride-sharing company to come to
the region they came and they saw that
um
most people couldn't pay right so
many people went to the bank and they
got their first
credit card many of them got debit cards
but then what you find is that debit
cards in most of these places are not
enabled for
for e-commerce
so then then we came in and what what we
did was
we enabled uber both to accept payments
from the from uh the the
the riders and but also pay the drivers
right
also pay the drivers yes and also accept
payments from the drivers because what
happened was that
at one point they said okay let's allow
the drivers to accept catch payments
okay so i think the very first place
where they tried it was
i may be wrong but i think it was peru
well in peru you could
pay the driver in cash but then at the
end of the week
the payments uh the payment was reversed
instead of paying the driver you needed
to collect the commission from the
driver
incredi incredible how you know similar
services have to make these adaptations
for the local culture norms that
that they have because you know here in
the in in you know imagining in
california going into an uber and trying
to pay them in cash it's
uh it's you know unheard of
what happened was that the moment they
started accepting cash
the the sales are actually the the
rights went through the roof of course
and sometimes it's it in many many cases
it's
a very big differentiator you want to
uh to accept more payment methods so
it's a competitive advantage against
your your competition but how does
d local actually make that
that adjustment how do you you know
mitigate
between the two sides so let's say you
go to peru
or uruguay or some other country and
uber wants to come in low credit card
penetration
how do you deal with that okay first of
all we are integrated today with the
over 300 different payment methods wow
and i didn't know there were so many
sorry
i didn't know there were so many
payments before there are more there are
even more
so each one of our customers customers
call the merchants which is the
companies they decide which
type of payment methods they want to
accept and of course there are different
fees for the different payment methods
so you have a
different uh networks and local uh
credit and debit cards and bank
transfers and wallets
and there are literally thousands
uh so when when they go to into a market
we work together we have a team of uh
what we call technical accounting
managers
that are engineers that work together
with the customer and we decide
what is the best integration to use what
is the best payment method
for each each particular a customer for
instance if you are
a netflix it's a it's a subscription
model right so you want a payment method
that you can
pull money from the account you don't
want the person to have to go and pay
with cash
or maybe you do want but if you want uh
the customer to pay in cash maybe you
want to charge them
every three months instead of every
month right you need to fine tune that
and it's very important that
we actually know which one of those
markets we have people on the ground in
each one of the
of the countries that we serve so how
many how many you're saying you have
people on the ground in each of these
countries
how many people are involved with d
local right now
uh we're around the 280 people now wow
very fast we'll be uh we'll be over 500
there by next year
by by next year yes that's incredible
okay and you're okay so so so now the
the given question is what is it like to
you know run
such a fast-growing company at you know
emerging markets i mean it's you know
during covet most people are firing you
are hot you're doubling your size within
a year
yeah we hired the since coming started
we have we've hired the i don't remember
the exact number probably around 30
people
it's very challenging to uh to bring
people in when you cannot
be face to face of course the culture it
is it is hard
and for me it's very easy because i'm no
longer a ceo of the company we have a
ceo
who is much younger and he lives in
israel by the way
but it is a it is very very challenging
we have a lots of very young people
uh our ceo is
i believe 29 years old i'm not sure if
he's third yet
um but but isn't it challenging that the
leadership team has to
you know when you're thinking of a new
market to enter or the new adaptations
you have to make to different
to different you know emerging markets
you have to really understand their
culture you have to
be sort of you need to be local right d
local you need to be local to that
market
so how do you mitigate this the fact
that the leadership team
perhaps is from israel or is that you
know is like from
different places in the world and all of
a sudden they have to make strategic
decisions based on an emerging market
that they don't necessarily
empathize with we travel a lot we have
local people
um probably the most challenging market
for us was
china actually and what we did in china
is
we recruited a team over there of course
we started with one
key person but we recruited a team
of around 15 people and we saw we sent a
few people
that were working with us for a long
time
which are living in in china uh so we
try to
to mix the company culture with the
local culture
so they both work together it's it's not
easy this is
quite quite challenging but but again we
need to have
we do have local people in each one of
the markets
uh because that's the only way that we
can really understand the markets
amazing okay tell me a little bit about
we we get together once a year
with all the team and then we
work very hard with the on the culture
and they're actually between the people
well okay sir joe talk to me a little
bit about entrepreneurship and
innovation in latin america
and what is the scene like where is it
headed
and what are some of the most exciting
opportunities
that you know i could be excited about
as a young entrepreneur
uh let's say if i want to enter this
market and to make an
impact a good impact on the on the
market as a whole
well first of all i'm i'm a very
firm really believer that
entrepreneurship is
uh it is everywhere and actually
the more challenging the environment the
more entrepreneurship you have you go to
i don't know you go to a place like uh
like india for example
and everybody needs to be
entrepreneurial because otherwise
even out of doing some basic tasks that
in the us
are so simple right requires you to be
a creative and find your ways around it
definitely
so i think that entrepreneurship and
innovation
happens everywhere it's no longer
something that comes out of the silicon
valley and they think that
post copied after companies
got used to a hiring remote the moment
that you're hiring remote
the border doesn't mean anything anymore
nothing so if you are going to hire a
remote the person
can be sitting in in sunnyvale right
in new york or in argentina it doesn't
matter so so you expect this to
accelerate the
to accelerate you know the the
productivity of the markets
that until now they were they were not
they were didn't have access to a lot of
these companies because of geography
now the engineers over there and the
people who are able to work in tech they
can
they can work and they often work at
cheaper prices right
absolutely i mean it doesn't have to be
cheaper prices say
but it's as a company it opens
it opens the whole world and there is
talent everywhere
everywhere right and for every i don't
know for every
uh uruguayan that is working in the
valley there are
10 other rewards that are as talented
and that
they don't want to leave they want to
leave no no of course and
when i mentioned the cheaper prices i
meant
only in the sense of you know here the p
my friends are paying
2500 a month rent plus you know twenty
dollars a meal
to uh three times a day to just to eat
you go around the world
to any place it's it's not the same
prices so in order to have a similar
lifestyle
you don't need to get you know an
entrance salary
of 130 140 k as an engineer
of course yeah right um so
back back to your question um there are
many many exciting
things happening in latin america
fintech is one of them
banks here are very very old-fashioned
very inefficient um so
in all the different areas of fintech
there are many things going on
in payments in landing in insurance
uh you name it there are
there are things happening um
again as i said before um in fintech in
particular regulators are very
are very key player in in that ecosystem
so and they are starting to see that at
the end of the day
they need to to provide consumers with
more
more options being careful of course
because you want to make sure that there
is no
money laundering or anything bad going
on
um so that's one area everything
cross-border is super exciting i am
an investor in a cross-border e-commerce
company
and with again with coffee
sales are going through the roof it's
amazing what's what's going on in that
market
um wonderful many companies that are
doing uh software development and
testing for
abroad uh sorry about that no problem
uh what else um
proptech there's a lot going on um
essentially you you have many
many companies that are clones of the
usa
usa and i've seen that as a trend that a
lot of us you know the
you know a lot of these emerging markets
they're looking at the successful
innovations of the us
and they're making a local adaptation of
them
uh into their country but but you know
sergio
before we leave i want to thank you
again for your time a 20 minutes always
go by so quickly and i always learn so
much from from these incredible
conversations
and but i have to ask the most important
question which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
i would say uh i'm
i'm very curious
i'm a international
and an entrepreneur
i love it curious international
entrepreneur sergio thank you very much
for the inspiration
and thank you for for everything that
you're that you've taught me and uh
and good luck with covet and i hope that
it can it will continue to be zero cases
also when this is published i really
hope so i really really hope to
take care thank you very much bye
bye